[Music]
i was there the year before but it
didn't mean that it was going to calm my
nerves
knowing that
all the eyes were going to be on me
i remember counting down
as it got closer and closer to my
category
finally it was time and william hurt
came up on stage
the nominees for performance by an
actress in a leading role are
and my heart was beating so hard and i
remember watching him
and he
opened the envelope
he looked right at me
and i wasn't sure why he was looking at
me
and then he signed my name
[Music]
and for the split second i thought that
he was teasing
that he was playing a joke but then i
thought well no he can't be playing a
joke on live television in front of
millions of people
watching the show
so i guess i won
[Music]
and i had no speech prepared
none
i was just 21 years old and i was so new
to the business i was just growing up i
just left home and i think that
terrified me more than anything
[Applause]
the long applause
was very touching for me
i mean their applause validated my work
because they voted for me
and that was a great feeling
and i just want to thank all of you
i love you
it's been 35 years since i won the
academy award and lots of things have
changed
i'm so fortunate that there are so many
other voices in the deaf community
voices that are being heard
and i'm pleased to see that
[Music]
you